new hope political renewal in Romania on
December 22nd Klaus Johannes takes
office the president-elect of Romania
surprised many when he emerged
victorious after polls November he says
one of his biggest priorities is
tackling corruption Johannes belongs to
romania's german-speaking minority that
may be an advantage as he seeks to carry
out his agenda in the interview
Romania's president-elect Klaus Johannes
loss Johannes if evolved from your
election to the office of President was
a big surprise for many added laughter
the first round your opponent incumbent
Prime Minister and socialist victoire
Ponte had a ten percentage point lead I
amplifon simple simple yet you were
always confident you would win you know
why he come to us if I thought lately
phone on phone I was convinced from the
beginning that I could win and that I
would win in bed because at the
beginning of the year I was already
traveling around a lot campaigning for
the European parliamentary elections
event that vodka beneath the oral Pavan
I came into contact with a huge amount
of people all the time if you Lord and I
noticed that something needed to happen
it's moose a people were simply waiting
for change waiting for something new
ending dolor de la vara it was neues
that's at me that certainly encouraged
me to enter the race for president
volcom football and from the very start
it made me sure that I had a very good
chance even deceased ah I nazar budesh
on Saba defense vada in there certainly
was a chance in the runoff polyone by
nine percentage points which surprised
your opponent what was the reaction from
his social democratic party after your
victory as part of this mr. Barrett's
elisa admittedly it was very surprising
for a lot of people between the first
and the second rounds of polling few
people believed that I could win problem
does he deserve argued there was a big
gap in the first round but my opponent
led by ten percent
st. present at the man gang candidate
for room all of my demonic evil on my
team were really quite worried on their
base or personally I was optimistic are
optimistic won't that the end result
showed that my optimism was well
grounded pegaron that my opponent and
the opposing party simply weren't ready
for the result the getting part i divide
it took them completely by surprise it
knocked them off balance sati fully you
brushed unlawfully Austin glass give it
give orphan give our slogan your
campaign slogan was simple and clear you
called for a Romania of thoroughness and
a Romania of work well done I'm sure you
have a list of priorities can you share
some of them with us we'll converse of
these Alistair state yeah Lana talisha
man virus that was my campaign slogans
it would be must of course it sounds
very good in Romanian when you translate
it it doesn't have the same impact but
the core message is something like this
things should be done fairly and
properly it was korek that I all soggy
will buy but my campaign began with the
question why do you want to run from the
start my answer was that I want Romania
to have a different kind of politics
hung on emerge there you little man I
want to change the way we do politics
mr. that's not that was the essence of
my campaign does is it centrally usagi
minus volcom for skivvies and undred
politicked assessed by a different kind
of politics I mean less show less
pointless talk and more solutions more
solutions for Romania and for the people
up cos in dolphin aside from that I plan
to be a different kind of President to
the ones we've had in the past you said
hutton I want to be a president who
brings things together zalman bring
their who takes the things that should
be closely aligned and brings them
together again with the alberto of
course I also want to be a fair but
strict referee on the Romanian political
landscape poorly decline soft son also
them as well
is that there are many many things in
Romania that must be improved must be
changed must be done better man of our
program does he race at eat something my
election manifesto focused on 11
important topics you get theme on that
also gives three those topics include
education 130 school health care it
gives one infrastructure the pension
system and many other things won't feel
and redina the la- in my opinion those
things require more than just simple
improvements some of them have to be
rebuilt from the ground up and under
sanjin with ANFO and Hong Kong creators
so let me name a concrete example but I
the area of schooling and the classroom
but that's what I'm convinced that what
we have now is not what Romania needs in
a North vendor youth when we go into
schools it's clear that we need a dual
schooling system it's like there is in
Germany Oh in leaf York in Deutschland
and dois does not every child wants to
get a high school diploma after 12 years
and then go to university let's then
technically Fionnula and I'll be too
obliging stood there are many who want
to learn basic but good trades I'm
[ __ ] about at the moment that's
really not so easy to do that garden he
does alike moogly gesundheit regarding
health care at the moment we placed the
patient somewhere on the margins of the
systems that what's in the patient must
be the focus of the system so we can
significantly improve health care and I
proposed similar approaches for many
other areas as well that I hear the
fortigate he's forgotten about your past
as a physics teacher and school
inspector probably informed your
opinions about education during the
campaign one of the things that was used
against you was that your from the
german-speaking minority people try to
make that a millstone around your neck
what it actually an advantage because
the german-speaking minority in Romania
is well respected in Romanian he has
picked yet yeah as I think it does yes I
think my opponent thought he could
easily attack me with that i mean i'm
good i think gun I don't think my
belonging to the German minority was a
disadvantage
at Seward ochen mean that hat but
whether or not it was an advantage if
and to what extent it helped us we'll
have to wait and see that's when Vera
nos in want of to the guns in tomorrow
want to stress two things on this topic
of political attacks I think about
during the campaign I always talked
about fighting corruption off lets them
together and it turned out to be
important namely the attacks and
counter-attacks of course and they
always have something to do with that
early model hitless tommy tutone he kept
if you like Nick guns phone on perhaps
not from the very beginning but from
early in the campaign the battle against
corruption was at the center of my
platform but iron through fear and by
coincidence it matched up with what the
Romanian anti-corruption authorities
have been doing especially in the last
few weeks thus it was very well received
and I think we should keep going with it
almost 100 fear in the firefight that
motion in on pollito sanjay kapoor in
terms of domestic policy you scored
points for that battle against
corruption and for strengthening
constitutional democracy and the rule of
law he also made a significant mark with
foreign policy on your first trip as
president-elect you traveled to the
capital of moldova kishi now two days
before their parliamentary elections
that was a strong statement whiticus i
think what an for tagging does it's me I
simply wanted to show that I was
interested in what was happening in the
Republic of Moldova Romanian owned d
république monomania and Moldova and
have so much in common no Phyllis
gemeinsam history language culture
economics that I felt I wanted to make
that statement see here alpha answer his
sessions it's an volt lawyer and
recently moldova has put itself on the
path towards european integration Dhavan
gil oona and then vic Nahor open so
treated as fun I found that very
important and I've stressed that again
and again Romanian via Romania must and
will support Moldova on that path
moldavian unterstützen but thus east- in
my view it's the right path for our
brothers across the prutte
we call them in that this booth we
assess the 10k dusty resultado de Valle
it's the van that Parliament's one
destined I think the result in the
recent parliamentary elections show that
the citizens of Moldova understand that
the path towards Europe is better than
the other cavities arts and Andre
Allison Polly design it's an important
statement also because of the crisis in
Ukraine Romania is an 80 and an EU
member European Union how are you
handling the crisis myth especially
given the fact that in Moldova there are
fears it could spread into the breakaway
region of Transnistria I think under 50
foot transnistria will hope knits
laterally elastic of course we hope that
the crisis won't spread and that things
will slowly start returning to normal
normality paciotti think it does Vidya
teen and I think we're now in a
geopolitical situation where Romania
can't and isn't expected to act alone
nay minh con order is all but to act in
a partnership with others rahman
romanian is Romania is in three such
partnerships meet andreen want is a
partner they guarantee Romania security
in this extremely exposed regions it
explained they provide us with a
practical approach to solving the
Ukraine crisis so losing desert
crescendo khurana the synthesis first
ently those partnerships I mentioned are
of course first NATO for Anakin study
also the strategic partnership with
united states that an romania's place
within the year total patient unknown in
these are sea dog i think that in this
situation individual actions are not
useful and not needed so then it's
better to approach problems together
with our partners until such time that
we can hopefully put this crisis behind
us bart is it easy and all be part of a
region where international agreements
are adhered to involve the internets on
an OP common belf that vertin some flew
to finish mr. your highness let's return
to the german-speaking minority in
Romania
you're what's called a Transylvanian
Saxon how important is that for
bilateral ties between Romania and
Germany opiates minus will give Eddie
katsudon but i'm not sure if my
belonging to the Transylvanian saxon
community is important or not but the
main thing is that i know a great deal
of German politicians some of them very
well arts Luger much as mayor of ham
onstott and a few years ago as the
chairman of a democratic form of germans
in romania i nurtured contacts dr. i
still have these contacts and i want to
use them for the good of romania off
before bursting to improve and deepen
ties between germany and romania even
for veteran debates humans vision
romanian on deutschland of NZT honest
thank you danke